hello
uh
the hair showed award is given to an
individual in the motion picture
industry
who's humanitarian efforts have brought
credit to the industry
to his cause Michael J fox has brought
understanding empathy and resolve
and with it inspiration to Millions who
now stand a little taller speaking of
voice a little stronger and hold on just
a little tighter
to something all of humanity needs a
whole lot more of
hope
I was at a party in Hollywood and uh I
don't recall the specifics of the time
other than it was in the mid-80s and uh
it was a Thursday
and it was about 8 34 P.M
other than that I don't really remember
but uh naturally I was in the kitchen
where all good parties end up
and I just stepped outside for a little
air
and uh and suddenly you know I come back
seemed like everyone at the party just
evaporated
so I walk into the living room and there
is everybody watching
a television show
so I stopped and watched
and there was this kid who looked to be
in high school on the screen
and he was
Electric
what he could do with a look
or a pause
you know I was watching a phenomenon in
the making
and I mean I I think of myself as pretty
funny and very funny when I'm high
[Laughter]
but this guy was a master class in
comedy and that was my first interject
introduction to Michael J fox
[Music]
a year or two later uh he did Back to
the Future he was the biggest star in
the world
uh uh and we were having a cheers
Christmas party I know you remember this
Mike and he came by and this was when I
first actually got to meet him and he
was incredibly gracious
and he loved the show and Ely loved my
character I will say
and uh you know he was he has this
amazing ability when people approach him
to tell him how great he is he turns the
tables and he makes those those people
feel great and I would see him do this
so many times over so many years
uh you know Mike is he's a genuinely
great guy I mean what can I say he's
Canadian uh and we we uh we had a nice
chat and then he got up on stage with
the band who was doing Johnny B Goode
and he did his solo from Back to the
Future
and I can tell you everyone
from the Cheers cast and crew felt very
lucky to witness this performance
other than one lady
who was not feeling Christmassy and who
promptly kicked him out
and that woman became my wife
[Laughter]
so it's a cheap joke no but anyway uh
so I I had this company making uh round
beach towels so now when the the sun
moves your towel doesn't have to
yeah this is I tell you it was another
one of those Savant Investments that
that's really kept me in fine Federal
all these years uh so I brought over to
Mike a couple of towels as an apology
for getting kicked out of the party and
he said let's hang out sometime and I
said okay yeah let's hang out sometime
and and we became good friends uh a bit
later he recommended me for a part in a
film called Doc Hollywood
and
that's good the old people cheering but
it was it was my LEAP from uh cheers to
the big screen and I owe it to you Mike
and uh
uh
but anyway one morning while we were in
Florida his pinky was twitching and he
he wasn't sure it was if it was from the
20 minutes of slap boxing we'd done in
the parking lot the night before so he
saw a doctor
who was the first doctor who suggested
to him he might have Parkinson's
uh he told me
and I I just couldn't believe it because
there's such an invincible superhuman
quality about Mike all of you who know
him know that's true
well he never missed a step never
wallowed in self-pity as I would have
done
and instead he turned to chilling
diagnosis
into a courageous mission
I went to visit him in Thailand when he
was filming casualties of War
and one night Mike took us to the end of
the Jungle and we stopped at this little
Hut
and Mike you know ran out of the car
this kid runs up to him and he hands him
like thousands of Bot which probably
amounted to about 16
and then the kid led him to this little
space that had a chest high wall of
concrete around it and they both jumped
over it
so I run up to the wall
I couldn't believe it you know I look in
there and Mike is sitting next to this
kid
with dozens of cobras all around them
ready to strike
and not no jest and and the uh and the
kid was touring with these with these
cobras he would stick his knee in front
of him you know and then the Cobra will
try to strike and he'd just move his
knee in time and then just smack him in
the back of the head
he taunted a bunch of these cobras and
then he found the ornery is Cobra
grabbed it by the neck threw it in a
cage with the Mongoose where I saw the
craziest fight I've ever seen
between any animals other than Studio
executives
and uh
you guys know I'm kidding of good uh and
the Mongoose one
they took the snake
yeah tied it by its tail rung the Blood
Out Half filled four glasses with Cobra
blood and half with Thai whiskey
drinking the Cobra blood is called
becoming brother to the snake
um Mike and I drank lots of things
together
and he can hold his own what can I say
he's Canadian
but Mike promptly vomited his snake
cocktail he never could hold his uh
Cobra blood uh anyway I said I thought
well I thought I I thought it was one of
the funniest jokes I ever said I said
hey Mikey he likes it
good
oh yeah well they didn't get it last
then but it's it's gratifying now anyway
the famed acting coach Stella Adler
reminded us
that the word theater comes from the
Greeks it means
the seeing place
it is a place people come to see the
truth about life
Michael J fox never asked for the role
Parkinson's patient
or disease advocate
but make no mistake it is his greatest
performance
Michael brought the world to the singing
place where we all feel invested in
finding a cure for a cruel disease
vulnerable
yes
a victim
never
an inspiration
always
and a
and a living breathing symbol and
singular voice to help Advance progress
toward a cure through the Michael J fox
foundation for Parkinson's research
so far he's raised over one billion
dollars for the cause
someone once told me people will
remember your example not your advice
and I advise them is that necessarily
true no but Mike Michael J fox sets the
ultimate example of how to fight
and how to live
and today he is as beloved for his
activism as he is for his acting
please join me for a look at the life
and a snapshot of the story of someone
who's immense Talent
is surpassed only by the depth of his
courage and his commitment to a cause I
love you brother